help me when somebody please help me i'm
lost and i can't see
it echoed through the alley in a thin
reedy voice that suggested brittleness
of body and spirit who wouldn't hear
that cry and feel a pang of sympathy are
you so heartless that you'd ignore the
desperate pleas for help of a blind man
clearly in distress for all you know he
might even be in danger what if he walks
into a road and gets hit by a car would
you really want that on your conscience
questions like these were flying through
the head of the good samaritan when he
decided to go and investigate when it
seemed like everyone else was just
content to pretend they didn't hear it
and carry on with their day as normal
the good samaritan was a person not
unlike yourself they were also the kind
of person we all hoped and wished we
would be in a situation such as this
kindness and generosity is a virtue
after all the problem is there are
people out there who know this and are
willing to take advantage of that
kindness and generosity but even worse
is the fact that there are things that
are definitely not people out there
willing to take advantage of human
compassion too but back to the good
samaritan he approached the sound of the
distressed man in the alley he looked
old and frail hunched over with the
weight of his ears he wore thick dark
glasses and his white cane was laying on
the road a few feet away from him it was
a tragic scene but thankfully the good
samaritan was here to help he approached
the old man calmly telling him that it
would be okay the good samaritan picked
up the walking cane and passed it over
to the blind old man his face spread
into a warm smile and he said
thank you thank you thank you young man
it warms my heart to know there are
still good people like you on this earth
the old man told the good samaritan that
he'd come into town to get some fresh
air and a little exercise at which point
he'd gotten lost when the good samaritan
asked whether it was safe for him to
come alone the old man told him that he
always used to go on walks with his wife
but ever since the accident she didn't
seem to want to be seen in public the
good samaritan naturally felt for the
old man who seemed as sweet as he was
feeble he offered to escort the old man
back to his house personally wanting to
make sure that he returned home safely
the old man smiled and graciously
accepted saying that his wife would
probably want to thank the kind young
man for helping him in person of course
the good samaritan was so wrapped up in
the warm glow of doing a good deed that
he never once stopped to question the
strangeness of this whole situation he
just walked along with the old man
listening to him tell his fanciful
stories as they left the city center and
crept further into the sleepy outskirts
of their small kentucky town
he was just rambling on as old men tend
to do he told the good samaritan a
little more about his beloved wife she
was a kind woman who'd he'd known for as
long as he could remember his elementary
school sweetheart then his high school
girlfriend and not long after they
graduated his beautiful blushing bride
oh yes she'd always been the prettiest
lady until the accident curiosity was
getting the better of him the good
samaritan couldn't help but ask what
exactly the accident he kept alluding to
was and the old man was all too happy to
give him an answer not that this answer
was in any way pleasant his wife had
been trapped in a terrible fire in town
that gave her severe burns all over her
body she was lucky to be alive the
flames took her beauty and her
confidence away from her since then
she'd become a real homebody often
refusing to leave the house and rarely
ever letting strangers see her the good
samaritan's heart ached for this poor
old couple why were such nice people
often forced to endure so much suffering
did this old man even have anyone else
to talk to they reached his house soon
enough it was the furthest one on the
end of the street right next to the
darkness of the woods it looked old and
dilapidated but it wasn't like the old
blind man could even know that as they
were walking up the small set of stairs
to the porch the old man stumbled
slightly causing his thick dark glasses
to fall to the floor the good samaritan
reflexively leaned over to pick up the
glasses for the old man as he passed
them back he noticed something strange
the old man wasn't just blind he
literally didn't have any eyes just two
black empty sockets where his eyes
should be the good samaritan was just
thankful that the old man wasn't able to
see him staring as he put the glasses
back on the two of them entered the
house the good samaritan was too busy
thinking about the old man's empty eye
sockets to even notice him locking the
door behind them and by then it was
already too late for him the old man
called out into the dark expanse of the
house sweetheart
i've got you alive one
before the good samaritan could ask what
he actually meant by that the old man
shuffled off deftly navigating the halls
through memory alone and took one of the
two seats at the dining table he just
sat there smiling waiting that's when
the good samaritan heard the creaking
sound coming from above something moving
up in the darkness of the second floor
and then descending the stairs with
heavy clumping footsteps when his eyes
came into focus in the dark he saw it
there the most terrifying thing he'd
ever witnessed coming down the stairs
towards him it was vaguely human in its
shape alone but in all other respects it
was a monster through and through this
gnarled twisted creature with bulging
eyes dead flesh and filthy exposed fangs
like it stepped straight out of a
nightmare and into the physical world
where it did not belong there looked to
be a huge hole in its lower torso too
with no blood or organs inside just an
infinite blackness the creature's
lipless mouth twisted into a smile the
creature said something in a voice that
the good samaritan couldn't understand
it was the black tongue something
ancient terrifying and unknown as the
creature got closer and closer the good
samaritan turned and made a run for the
door he tried to figure out the lock his
hands fumbling and uncoordinated by fear
he could hear the footsteps and the
heavy breathing of that thing getting
closer behind him he was so close almost
there that's when a strange black
substance seemed to encase the world
around him it separated him from the
door he was so nearly able to breach
locking him in he was trapped inside
what looked like a giant black sphere
made of some unknown material or energy
he turned to see that monster standing
right behind him just grinning and
waiting for the inevitability of the
situation to sink in the good samaritan
had never been more terrified something
else began to shift inside the sphere a
structure was growing out of the ground
up and around him like a cage within a
cage he was trapped and huddled inside a
strange conical structure as more
figures entered the sphere around him
they were just like the first this
horrible horde of desiccated not people
all with grinning lipless mouths when
they closed in on him the good samaritan
had the one consolation that at least it
was over but it wasn't not yet the blind
old man waited in the kitchen for five
hours as unmentionable horrors unfolded
inside the black sphere the good
samaritan was actually lucky all in all
because for some sessions for victims
inside the sphere had lasted as long as
27 hours he screamed the entire time
with a sphere finally demanifesting just
moments after the screaming stopped
remaining was only one of the creatures
but no good samaritan just several neat
piles of human organs arranged by organ
type are you down in there honey the
blind old man asked i've been getting
awfully hungry the creature replied in
perfect english yes yeah
i think you are
before
[Applause]
the creature picked up some of the
discarded organs and took them into the
kitchen where it began cooking them into
a stew for the old man he ate the stew
not long after blissfully ignorant to
its contents and went to sleep whatever
organs from the good samaritan weren't
used in the stew were simply thrown into
the fireplace to burn away into ashes
later that night the old man would die
peacefully of a heart attack in his
sleep at age 81. he spent the latter 10
years of his life in service of scp-957
he'd never even had a wife and when the
monster first invaded his home he wasn't
even blind he'd simply come home one day
to find scp-957
lurking in his home waiting for him as
far as the scp foundation is aware it
always targets people who live alone the
man had tried to resist but the creature
was freakishly strong in spite of its
wiry frame
it grabbed him and forced his body into
the dark gaping chasm of its chest he
was swallowed up into another world on
the other side of the void and returned
four hours later a changed man his eyes
were gone and he now firmly believed
that
scp-957 was his beloved if burnt scarred
wife of many years he'd do anything for
her even heading out into the world in
feigning distress to lure people back
into her terrible clutches that's how
the old man became scp-957-1
he wasn't the first and wouldn't be the
last with the old man now dead
scp-957 would demanifest and head off in
search of a new victim invading their
home and repeating the cycle once more
somewhere else the somewhat happy ending
is that in one of these cases the scp
foundation somehow got wise to the
baiting activities of scp-950
and they were able to contain the
creature giving it the ketter object
class for its frequent attempts to
either get out or lure in new victims
it's never been actively hostile to
foundation researchers and guards just a
little obtuse
despite the fact that it's perfectly
capable of speaking fluent english it
prefers to speak in an unknown dead
language for somewhat mysterious reasons
very little is known about the origins
or true nature of scp-957
but our brief glimpse into its interior
life does little to comfort us in 2008
the foundation recorded 957 having a
conversation with an unseen individual
in its native tongue foundation
linguistic experts have been able to
partially crack the code on what was
being said that day 957 asked the unseen
figure how much longer it would have to
stay here the figure told it that it
would need to wait there for a while and
that its disguise was extremely
convincing 957 complained that being
here was boring and tiresome but the
unseen figure urged 957 to remain
patient it said
now go check out
scp-1861 the crew of the hms winter
shimer and scp-5049 the skin salesman
demon dan's discount homunculus depot
for more of the most terrifying
anomalous beings out there